[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté qu'est ce que vous allez nous
préparer aujourd'hui élu aujourd'hui
c'est excellent on va faire une paella
la côte basque
stop la deluxe disons parce que
tellement de choses devant nous un des
vols mais alors c'est un plateau est
très nombreux oui il faut mettre au
moins un minimum 10 personnes hyper
savoie vite et ses amis un jour d'été on
sait tous ensemble nous en sommes ce
plat complet on bavarde unités et voilà
parce que c'est assez long c'est assez
l'info il deux heures de préparation au
moins deux heures de préparation donc on
a bien le temps de se raconter le but
sur but
mais la première histoire c'est
qu'est-ce que vous allez nous mettre
là-dedans eh bien il faut mettre pas mal
de choses
il faut mettre tout de suite du poulet
du poivron tu la perds on peut rajouter
du port scion veut et c'est presque
nécessaire des moules des frères
dessèche des coques des champignons des
carottes des poires des tomates pardon
alors là il ya eu sur franck est
excellent
oui ou non j'ai toujours vu dans les
magasins du safran rouge en coin qu'il
est allongé bien c'est parfait parce que
c'est ça c'est le vrai safran des indes
le véritable cerveau celui qu'elle est
le bois exactement après faut du riz il
faut des langoustines
il faut des amendes et il faut des
normes par des grosses crevettes et des
amendes
ils sont pas du tout des amendes légumes
ou fruits comme on dit au nom des
coquillages de coquillages os 6 -
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire en famille et
bien on va commencer par faire le
couillon
qu'est ce qu'il nous faut eh bien il
nous faut tous ceux petits légumes c'est
à dire l'oignon les carottes de l'ail de
l'échalote et des parures de poisson a
bien alors on va mettre ça dans notre
cocotte à bouillir où vous aviez mis de
l'eau salée pour saler et poivrer
la voilà c'est ça il faudrait bien
entendu voilà et on va y mettre dedans
oui non langoustines qui sont superbes
et qui vont devoir très convaincant aux
deux minutes heure 10 minutes sont
jolies et on va y rajouter non en basse
ah bon parce que les gambas je croyais
enfin c'est bien contente pas il ya
autant de méthodes mais on peut aussi
les cuire au dernier moment viol rit oui
mais vous la vie aujourd'hui donc voilà
on va les faire cuire là parce
qu'autrement on les installe sur la vie
vous allez voir tout à l'heure où elles
le peuvent
très bien cuire aussi c'est aussi bon
comme c'est trop souvent comme ça ça
fait rien on l'a très bien dit est très
bien et on va les faire cuire à laisser
cuire 10 minutes
pendant ce temps on va s'occuper des
coquillards exactement il y a les boules
des prêts relais qu'offrent les amendes
qu'on va me faire ouvrir dans notre côté
on était ouvrir tous les ans sur le feu
tout simplement sur le feu on met tout
ça dans la cocotte là on apprend aux dix
minutes s'est remis plus de temps que ça
ou juste attendre et on gardera
précieusement le jure alors ça nous
laisse le temps de voir ces horreurs de
l'appeler discussions les 16 juillet à
nîmes à la baignoire mais mais c'est
excellent
quand même alors on a bien fait vous les
vidéos les fidèles
c'est très désagréable parce qu'à une
encre et birmans bien parce que ça non
si toutes les mains oui voilà c'est
merveilleux j'ai réussi j'ai gagné tout
enfin oui j'ai tout gagné
les marchands du pressoir ont pu dire
que c'est bon et c'est là excellent nom
à voile à lorient 9e noces lorsqu'on
donne à manger aux oiseaux d'oiseaux et
dans lequel quelque rugueuse animal
quand même là sachez que les voilà on
les a coupés en lanières
on va les mettre de côté et on va
s'occuper de nouveaux visages
alors il devra mettre à peu près à
windsor traître à victoria on va les
sortir
oui les mettre dans un saladier tout en
essayant de garder le trot du jus qui
est excellent
alors vraiment besoin d'hésiter s'agit
bien entendu
[Applaudissements]
là et voilà c'est de les mettre de côté
on les met de côté comme les avis voilà
on va les mettre là et le jul qu'est ce
que vous en faites je suis on va le
mettre ici ici c'est à dire avec le
lendemain le couillon renvoyons de
l'organe en bottines élégantes barre
parce que ça c'est bon on va mélanger
les deux voilà je vais mettre tous on va
les gestions on va s'en occuper tout à
l'heure et donc maintenant il sera
peut-être temps de s'occuper du poulet
de la poule a de la peine à pieterlen
vous avez coupé le pool elle n'a pas en
très petits morceaux à maïs et vingt
huit ou dix morceaux chaque ascension
peut et qu'est ce que vous allez en
ferme est bien vrai faire dorer dans
quoi dans notre gré son huile ou grains
en ce sens mais voilà alors remettre un
peu d'huile d'olive pour donner vos lui
aussi exactement quand je vais le salé
le poivre et oui pareil on va les faire
dorer voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors vite et quand même le temps que
j'adore on a quand même un petit moment
est ce qu'on pourra pas en profiter
c'est pouvoir qui s'ac du côté des
langoustines les langoustines sans
commission eh bien on a le sentiment
qu'il était là ça la fameuse aurait pas
d' inception
elles sont belles
attention ça doit être très ambitieux et
on va garder naturellement très précieux
combustion les deux premières et je mets
ça naturellement de côté ou écossais
autant dans ce temps pendant ces deux
ans vous allez me dire pour nous les
noirs on va mettre d'abord les sèche
parce que les sièges sont ceux qui l'ont
acquise
oui je le reste voilà on va s'emballer
superbe la création réduire sa malle ou
louis et pour ça tout haut eh oui on
aurait du pain chaud ce faire là on va
pas relancer à lille il faut avouer
parce que c'est déjà de souffle oui on
va les coups viennent petit peu et on va
rajouter le reste insuffisant alors en
suivant j'ai bien compris la leçon si
son lit commun des tomates coupez la
dernière là intervient vous en ai
préparé un père me donne encore une pour
vraiment dans le plein c'est un concert
que je travaille si vous pouvez voilà
les autres c'est pareil on va remettre
tout le reste
la remuer tout ça parce que ça fait la
grèce vont jouer et c'est très joli et
ça me réjouit
et ce n'est pas tout parce qu'il ya
encore les champignons qu'on imagine y
ont répondu eh bien c'est ça c'est
difficile ça arrange ça donne un bon
parent seront aussi là je vais remettre
du sel du poivre pour les champignons où
ils sont simples femmes oui là du seul
fois votre léger et on laisse mijoter
centre évolué tout petit peu prendre
moins au mieux un tout petit peu et la
première qu'est ce que vous allez avoir
à mettre du bouillon à du bouillon de la
cuisson de la mousseline
c'est à dire le court bouillon et
nanjing auquel on ajoute
et l'aude exactement m vous allez
ajouter la baignoire tous remplis mon
retour en pire voilà ce que faisait le
poulet en le pas comme ça il est beau et
on va le faire jusqu'à ras bord il faut
que ce fait que ça soit là ça va
bouillir ça donne un bon goût ça c'est
difficile
la paella à venir réduite oui on va
s'occuper des coquillages mais c'est à
dire qu'on a déjà enlevé quelques
couvertures on va les finir ça c'est pas
décoration pas il faut se rappeler qu'on
les avait fait ouvrir à la cocotte
justement l'équipe ne sont pas tout à
fait cuit mais embarque voilà alors
remettre cela d'abord oui on va rajouter
cela ici dedans voilà moi je suis ni
d'enlever les couvercles
oui et je vous donne les autres alors
seul un jeu vih et à verser dessus
d'abord parce que le père suspecté
cuisse d'autant que le reste va
grossièrement comme ça et oui voilà
valley m voilà ça dans le bon goût et je
vous donne tous et toutes
et on donne tout ça n'est ce pas moi qui
ai bien mélanger très bas les masques
commandés big ben bon voilà on va mettre
les cotisations non on en être un peu
partout même partagé voilà voilà alors
que tel qu'on peut dire que ça avait
réduit pendant à peu près amis du tennis
bonne demi heure est à peu près un quart
d'heure avant de servir
nous supposons cite ainsi oui il est
temps de mettre le riz de mettre le fils
alors le riz vous l'ajoutez tout
simplement de riz on ajoute tout
simplement dedans et puis très très bien
alors vous mais c'est en pluie comme
ceux ci à peu partout un peu partout la
5ème vous en mettez vous n'avez diyala
moussa maghrebi personne personne et sur
le kilo de viande il faut le kilo de
voile à en cerner on vous allez voir en
vendant le 5 a commencé là on en met
partout
voilà et maïté si j'ai bien compris ce
que me dit à partir de ce moment-là
falloir surveiller plus dans la douane
suisse a bien trop sec
ils formaient un petit peu du court
bouillon oui saft à mesure que le rival
gonfler la langue m et puis nous restera
et vous allez nous expliquer il nous
restera les langoustines arrangé par
dessus voyez dans leur mettre un petit
peu pour que ce soit bien fait la sig
ans le aussi voilà il faut plus la
touche et il ne faut plus la revue est
pratiquement pas voulu toucher la
surveiller et surveiller le royaume sans
armure et qui sont retournés qui
torturent s'imposerait l'appareil ne se
remue pas hors la loi la diana si vous
croyez la vie voilà bien mouillé et
ensuite eh bien on va préparer de
langoustines pour la décoration
exactement on ne dispose artistiquement
voyez on prend la france
doucement parce que ça craquait et on
accrochera que regarder ce faisant la
leçon tendance voleuse nous font la pire
boîte et la région et allant vers le
nord on va mettre l'autre safran ah oui
là notre vraie s'offrant voilà le
processus safran disent oui faut pas
malin pour denis l'ardeur eu le goût et
la quantité qui couvre la nasa va vous
devez tout y est un tout petit peu a
bien réduit presque plus et bien sûr de
france m là on va disposer de la revue
screen vous allez me laisser faire
passer les danseuses d'abord une rue oui
la jolie
voilà c'est beau et ça non vous disposez
comme ceux ci prennent quand sega et
l'autre on va mettre les gambas voilà
parce que vous m'avez expliqué tout à
l'air qu'on pouvait les faire cuire au
court bouillon comme nous avons fait
mais on peut aussi les maîtres cru à ce
moment là c'est à dire en fin de cuisson
oui payelle solives à la vapeur avec
solar dans le reste de l'ue
en prenant tous les goûts et ça suffit
cinq minutes à ce moment là ça aurait
suffi une autre technique en va mettre
maintenant des finances du poivre noir
en rouge e rima ont nommé comme ceux ci
en lamelles il faut prendre son temps
parce que ça fait joli une inversion des
concluses la pétition fait vite
et oui je les musées mal qu'on fait en
plus là
la paille a écrit et très belle on en
mange l'ami tout de suite tout de suite
mais oui le riz d'abord on la voit plus
sion le cas tellement d'évolution
tellement de bonnes choses voilà voilà
le riz sortir la regarde ou bois tout en
voilà et tout en collant et bien
maintenant inviter vos amis préparer
tout ça entre vous et bien rire et bien
vous amuser et puis vous allez bien
mangé ça sera un jour de fête bien
regard bon appétit à bientôt
à bientôt bon appétit
[Musique]